listen to talk box ELISA mentally do
hmm such mobility
hello grow hack this is a kind of an
unannounced stream so young here is on
vacation he has some spare time so we
decided to do to do a morning tournament
we haven't done that in a while well we
never actually did that I had some
morning tournaments but should be it
should be quite fun okay that we we have
some people already in the chat well
let's see who's here Hyperion for 193 yo
not Gabriel Burke xa a me Laguna at a
Soviet onion Soviet onion frags funk
gamer air K Joshua Herman hello everyone
it's 3:00 in the morning that's the best
time to play chess definitely so we
decided to do a short stream it's gonna
it's a 11 11:20 a.m. here probably gonna
last about 2 hours a tournament will
start in 10 minutes feel free to join
for those of you who are joining us for
the first time the link to the
tournament is in the description below
the password also password is YouTube 21
all capital letters and feel free to
join already nine players have joined
the tournament so I guess everything is
in order and Yann here is gonna be
playing the tournament and after that
we're gonna have some casual games if
anyone wants the challenge we don't have
some 11 minutes until the tournament
starts so we can accept some challenges
until then all only non rated since
we're both gonna be playing on the same
account it's it's only fair yeah hi guys
it's been a while your voice is going
down every now and then the microphone
yeah it's fine but it's directed to you
so okay I will just increase the gain a
bit
oh so there's been a while man yeah it's
been a while so mark morning tournament
let's see if we were ready for this yeah
okay
twenty people here we have you'd
apocalypse Giovanna right
Molly Mel my old rival Molly Mel is here
Neil guitar just in lieu are ZRX aboard
one go no-go and Stevo Bob five okay
should I show in a new tab right
oh yeah you can you can use the new tab
to accept a challenge or two before the
tournament starts okay let's do that
a swagger 66 the link to the tournament
is in the description below just click
on it and the password is the password
is YouTube 21 all capital letters okay
yeah he is going to reach hundred K soon
ball Gorgon is at work so he's gonna
miss the action are you really going to
miss the action
I know I know some people who who joined
from work
[Laughter]
Frank funk just click on the link in the
description below
no this isn't the 2 million dollar
tournament that one is played in Saudi
Arabia don't feel that much money
yeah maybe in in sometime you know there
will be I don't think there'll be two
million but maybe maybe $20 cyfle Islam
Pavel says he will destroy everyone okay
10 minutes to begin it's too much well
it kind of gives people time to join I
don't think it's too much
a greeting greetings from Poland named
ina P Takako Thomas Niger a name Anya
hello from California we have we have
sir Bob Bob bobbington from Australia
here hello good sir
yeah I think there'll be time like for
maybe this challenge and one more before
the tournament starts but yes then we
can accept some challenges after the
tournament I will be right back okay so
guys I see again we are all over the
world
Australia Italy Hungary Arizona so isn't
it morning in America early risers or
going too late to sleep the pub the
password is YouTube 21 this time okay
Finland Brazil Turkey Australia again
India okay we have fans from all over
the world
Seychelles awesome okay let's see what
we have here I think I'm looking good
the B the B file is open I can push d5
can you push the fire but g5 is looking
nasty oh I'm going to put my ropes on C
and B maybe not just yet I can even play
this since I would like to suggest
anything because it might be bad ah
that's a good move
Queen c5 was a big threat it was it
though yes it was
[Music]
let's just protect and open the B file
and name your name next on I do
if you're talking about me mister Fajar
my name is Yann Almighty I'm a frequent
guy here at I'm a frequent guy live
chess tournaments not in the videos
though okay let's stop this taking 1f8
with what's up quite an intense game yes
it is I thought you will double up rooks
on the B file yeah but he kind of
stopped it no because if I move my rook
and Bishop to d6 was yes well you can
give up one rook
then how can I double them first you
give up one okay hey Enrico and Ronnie
I'll just take I'm going to left his
girlfriend for this well that's she's
quite a lucky girl
oh he loved that yes he did
well it okay yes that's he wanted to
trick you
so how much time you have left five in
five minutes is your challenge
yeah definitely we have a 1.5 look looks
looks fine ok let's try okay let's try
always played for so before is is the
best yeah like the guys in the rapid
tournament as you say yeah a lot of
e-force Hui 5 like Anand versus like oh
I watch the videos yes maybe it is gonna
be a joke Oh piano
oh yeah we're getting there yeah but I
have to remember from yesterday yeah
I'll try it they say you have to play it
once again but if he goes to Bishop c5
ok I never played it
ah that's that's I guess d3 No yeah you
don't want to go 95 oh yeah that that's
always popular I think before it doesn't
work now before before never works this
just will you play it or not Joshua
Herman we are both from Croatia and
there is no beer to today because it's
half past 11
yeah it's half past 11 it would be too
early for beer yeah a bit too early
Veselin Topalov is the best that guy
really knows how to play chess yeah hey
you missed the fried liver attack dude I
have to watch out can I take this yeah I
see no reason why not if I can take a
logistic area meal ah greetings from Sri
Lanka it's never too early for beer says
Frank yes that that is true we just
don't have any okay I just oh that's not
that's a strong center now yeah you're
gonna be very hard isn't going anywhere
remember Europe come on man no but we
remember the qualifying match that was
played mm I don't know do you know what
is the Yara game gambit here no you know
embedded openings I'm I've never heard
of Yara game gambit I'm gonna I'm gonna
have to check that one I never heard of
a fried liver until you told me what it
is are you occurred of it you just
didn't know it's called fried liver yeah
hey positive feedback I can't let's try
this and Bishop 23 maybe possibly okay
okay
well he is down 13 seconds so I don't
think it's a rookie eight is coming then
I take and take the Queen more I can
play oh okay
no yes yeah it's very
to be good summertime okay minutes Oh
Alda joined the tournament okay no she
was all very nice well there's a very
strong player yeah
judging by is raising seems seems like
seems like a good player but he is he
some known chess player wait no no no
III don't know we see international
master from France your score oh you you
beat him once yes I beat him in
hyperbolic okay I mean I think I managed
to checkmate him I think in three
minutes
what we'll have enough time what happens
in hyper bullet you know doesn't really
count
yeah but delicious keeps the score so
yeah it looks nice looks nice where is
the dog doggies Oh back here I don't
know if I in my chair
oh yeah he's just chilling you know yeah
I just had like three walks
ah yeah the tournament is rated I don't
I don't know if EML the 64 is in the
stream if you are here hello sir and and
thank you for for joining this
tournament it's an honor having you here
it's currently half past eleven in
Croatia
yeah that's a very British of you I was
talked to dot dot in school to say the
time like that ah he doesn't left me he
touch you gr says that Elda Elda is not
a sir oh okay it's my bad
catcha ducky
rakia I think interrelated soldiers a
British Indonesia thank you Elda Elda 64
is Paul Welton oh yeah yeah immediately
against Delta I guess I'll try my best
against Delta if L dice here it seems
he's offline oh no she won't mind okay
okay but they say it's Paul Welton so I
guess it is the key
I'm gonna have to check that out let's
try the clothes variation I know 26 okay
Oh elder says right now that says only
20 minutes okay night before Bishop says
to just
yeah I'll just take here now oxy 8 of
course Bobby Fischer said that more fuel
was the greatest genius well that's you
know that's a question it's really
impossible to answer that let's defend
ok a mr. weed good to have you here
oh yes G for I mean you're not gonna let
the night chill there on f5 of course so
LT is only here for 20 minutes
it seems so yes it's a shame well what
was the strongest opponent you've had in
in the tournament well in this live
Chester none was that you held elder we
have a record yeah I had been Feingold
once in the stream but he didn't want to
play he said he will play next time ok
let's just see so she's probably wanting
to play this dissing again here like
again I believe it's he okay but who
knows before a chronal dino is in the
chat a chronal dino should be three
before
yes password is youtube 21 or all
capital letters it doesn't matter the
tournament started everyone can still
join merry Christmas to you too Harry P
[Music]
okay that H 5 is certainly something to
think about
let's play kingi to will take and if she
plays night here I'll take with the
vision I will leave her with the bishop
pair but hmm but still let's see what
she had in mind
maybe sholdiers developed
so I I don't want to play g5 because
I'll tell them Elna says he can hear
your thoughts don't don't say what
you're gonna do
he feels like cheating and it's and he's
a boy I always talk out loud with ya
just I don't know why they said in the
chat you were a girl that really makes
no sense
okay was just played and okay
not talking is Elda 64 something like
Zelda 64
it seems like a decent position well
looks good let's see let's see what
happens
yeah I'll push my King and King to the
center just take yeah that's looking
fine um at some point - I I can't
suggest anything
okay yeah I will transfer my night just
to assist that's interesting I'm leaving
this but my plan will be rookie to on
rookie cheat but I like your plan as
well thank you what division I reached
in league of legends and second where
are you from speaking is like Rosie and
like Blair yeah I didn't reach platinum
I forest I got was qualifications for
platinum but that was a long time ago
yeah if I played you five then the rook
is trapped no let's try it certainly is
I mean Bishop e7 I can just can I take
ah L dice from Aragon the book oh no
because yeah [ __ ] this this was bound to
happen I yes oh she's also it's a he
it's a oh you can't use my move no this
is the best move now
yes David yeah check and then I take all
[ __ ] its we check come on [ __ ] I will
lose definitely on time but this is also
check no in this okay
but no everything's Oh everything is fun
but you know I think I got something
there but if you want to catch one
when I said we catch one it would have
been different
no probably it would be much better and
we have a feeling master James Bond here
also okay very nice a very strong turn
yeah let's see it seems that I this is
the first time I have two titles players
in a tournament I think the chess
players are morning guys it seems it
could be could be yes
okay a standard change variation of rule
or Lopez ceedric Wong says the character
from Aragon is Elva not Alda seems
interesting yeah you know Aragon but
what is Aragon aragorn like from no no
no ER Aragon no it sounds like sounds
like something okay if five looks
promising yes the king is still in sight
but you you really you really wound up
on that first game so now you can yeah
it was a it was a very nice game yeah
you didn't drink enough alcohol that is
true that is true but I would like to
play more games against him not her
Fran says how are you not feeling cold
it's freezing in the rear car where he's
at
we are inside so yeah and it's like have
you seen that movie Austin Powers
there's there's that fat guy and he has
this girl hostage and he asks her do you
know how we keep warm in Russia and she
says something like oh I can imagine
and he says we play chess so it seems
that yeah we need more of the motor
strings oh yes well I will try to do one
as often as possible but dreams are very
although stream is only like two hours
or you know however long you want it to
be but you have to prepare the stream
you have to prepare what do you do after
the stream have to take meadow for a
walk before the stream and you know
there's a lot of preparation for the
stream destroy indeed five here
just to see what happens
today you will get what you're a Bitcoin
master or what does this mean you will
get B 2x for your Bitcoin due to fork
happening hope you keep your Bitcoin in
a wallet I'm not really sure no I don't
know how do you have an interface like
this and how can I make it like yours or
that that's years and years of practice
okay seems so I'm waiting for towel
moves okay yeah it's hard to play Tom
moves when you wrap a piece but it's
easy to sacrifice a piece when you're up
a piece although there's really nothing
to sacrifice here yeah I'll just didn't
play here and then pushy for exchange
the bishops and then try to do something
on the okay or you can just oh thank you
screen I played the 95 now and he moved
oh yes
yep I'm just sticking to the my idea a
it young it's time for a haircut
so says Charlie Fuentes that is true
that was my plan actually yesterday but
we went for a beer instead yes now I
don't want to take the Queen because you
said I should do it yes it's the queen
is of the menu favorite chess player
definitely Vasily von Schuch okay play
this for kit
oh so now you're attacking the Queen
twice actually yeah oh okay
oh you missed that or now ah yeah wait
you didn't want to take it don't be - no
look
you could take it with your night you're
very generous man yeah yes favourite is
tall but favorite current one is even
Chuck I just take and bring back the
night and take care okay rook e8
threatening Bishop b4 and even 95 but I
think that's better
why did you primo who knows what you
will play that's my style
removing is the only way to move okay
now I think yeah this should be easy to
win both overrated as hell are we
talking about
hello like you and hello repose from
Lithuania the guys remembered those of
the engine yes though the engine will
always be remembered
let's but he might join us some day
again no yeah if if we have some wine
for example oh he's a wine guy yeah he's
a wine guy okay
oh you could you could get to checkmate
I doubt oh he's going for it yes now I
will check meet him oh it was almost a
draw yeah oh
Elda left yeah all the latter too but he
left as a winner two wins and he got one
rating point that's awesome so he would
have to win like 200 games to get at
least something why did this all play on
either for something tal played an idol
yes but I liked
this but he it you know sometimes he
played the tamaño but somewhere during
the eighties they figured the time on
off was a bad idea okay I mean I I
watched a lot of your videos and I saw
that a lot of people are actually
playing it so today I like it and I like
it and I just I I don't really know how
to play it I know how we usually set up
your pieces but I just want to try it
yeah just be three is a weird yeah I
mean now Bishop before probably but
Bishop theory was maybe no I'm
threatened 9 to d4 he cannot take
because this is a check if he okay yeah
there should be two dozen let's just try
this who is the highest rated chess
player in your country well if the
question is directed to us yeah I
believe it's even charged how would the
Spanish opening go against the Kings
Indian that is one weird sentence yeah
[Music]
okay Bromley if you have a Bitcoin in a
wallet to exchange will God grant the
new coins to you okay is it like the
same thing with Bitcoin cash where you
could get your the same amount of
bitcoins that you had I don't no idea oh
this is looking good for me
Jess eh that's actually not bad a lot of
countries don't even have even one Grand
Master no Croatia doesn't have a 2700 GM
maybe in rapid and or blitz but not in
classical yeah three sixes now I just
defend it see what happens
maybe he has some if he moves the knight
I've never met motto
unfortunately okay he's planning to go
queenside castle well just hey you wanna
positive Your Honor I just also go Queen
side do you have any tips for sir Bob
for his first tournament for okay tips
for the first tournament play well just
play a game yes every game at a time
like this
hmm I haven't seen the Kasparov master
class I've seen a couple of trailers but
not not the whole thing
you given up the rope Oh am i oh [ __ ]
okay didn't saw that sorry I'm really
not concentrated I think I should resign
okay no you could still win on time
come on he has a minute in ten seconds
oh this is really bad yeah but it's okay
you still have time to improve the
rating loss Oh 24 points okay I
shouldn't kill you or anything anymore
yes like you that that is a very
motivational and MIDI master James Bond
is climbing climbing up okay I saw some
requests for the Spanish cannot play the
Spanish the guy akshay wants to play the
Sicilian Oh
maybe he will show me how to play the
time on earth ah
Elda Elda messed up his username and
play chess calm he wrote Elda but he
actually wanted to go with everything
he's arriving in Paris soon okay okay
thank you for joining us Hilda and have
it yeah have a great time in Paris
especially if it's a chess tournament in
Paris okay I'm not sure if I'm in some
variation here or something but my night
is not a mainstream media doesn't show
just because mainstream media
I mean who watches mainstream media
greetings from Greece the masterclass
seems overpriced well I mean you do get
kind of a tutorial from from Garry
Kasparov himself I don't think that that
can be overpriced
Hey via KHOU isn't here or is via KO in
the chat
who's the most aggressive player now the
most aggressive player ah it's a tough
one do you mean most aggressive as he
gets angry quickly or or he plays the
most aggressive moves okay this guy is
really killing me with his
aggressiveness actually yeah I don't I I
wouldn't watch a sparse masterclass on
YouTube they really invested a lot in
that so wouldn't wouldn't be fair to
just watch it
okay what do we have here akshay 2200 oh
what's the idea here
probably play f5 but I like your pawns
yeah they're very nice pawns in the end
they are looking good
oh I probably shouldn't say what she
should play because he's playing it if
you if you're watching the world rapid
championship which is your favorite game
so far my question
no no to everyone okay why it might even
get some suggestions for next video
yeah Carlson could be the most
aggressive player but you know not not
on the board will vehicle be on the
stream I don't think so unless he
surprises us jumps out of the culture
yeah is into H 1 Tesla death-ray I don't
really feel like clapping for no reason
but if Jana wins this game with a
brilliant victory I will then applaud
him that that is not a problem although
you're a very long time yeah yeah no
because his is like playing very very
active moves all the time if you have to
really think what should I play next but
now I think I'm finally out of the
doghouse let's just see we'll just see
what happens okay
yeah that's what I thought he will play
but now
yeah okay okay and look here I guess
just a mock sigh I don't really
understand what do you mean show our
game live if you place the real code
just yeah don't care but I plan to I
think now fast moves are better than
good moves
rook come on man come on what are you
doing I'm not sure I'm not sure yeah I
wasn't I was planning actually to take
and then play 93 and everything's
looking great but you still have a nice
best c-pawn yeah which is what Kobe oh
no oh very nice I think you're still
gonna win this no I don't think earn
that applause I'm playing really bad No
oh he totally totally saw what you were
doing
Oh
it's very intense very intense there is
the concept of a kungfu drunken master
is there a chess equivalent of a chess
drunken master I actually know a guy who
really drinks a lot and he plays like
tall so you know there could be 227
players very nice that that's a lot of
players for for an unannounced
tournament well can you just check okay
after this game just to check the
standings okay yeah I'm too depressed
now to check how much points I'm behind
eight chess no max I think you mean
Esther and better you played against
Yann that game if you if you're
referring to the one in the tournament
Hawaii Tony says you messed that up man
you know really I was in a good position
then yes I were brilliant yeah but
you're a support I don't know what's
what so we told the blunders yeah I'm
not sure maybe maybe I should eat
something
I do you want a candy bar do you have a
energy bar yeah I mean it's a chocolate
bar so okay pretty sure there's a lot of
sugar in it yeah not if it will help
since we don't have beer a candy bar
will do oh that's very nice very nice of
you okay I'm looking good here yeah I
can feel it I can feel the victories
coming okay thanks okay that's fine
okay now the improvement will certainly
be seen yeah Tesla Edison
what about Tesla and Edison Sebastian
says show us why they call you almighty
there you go
will the bishop captures rook now
prepare for the wrath of Almighty tall
was cheating but not on the Carlson game
yeah that's well that is well known
we don't know where Draco is probably at
home or at work maybe who knows Draco is
a very mysterious guy hmm
Charlie says Yun needs a beer like
Popeye needs spinach that is true makes
you strong I should just play more
active okay no that's actually not true
he didn't cheat against Carlsen I will
open the G file for my king what do you
mean by take it mouse please I don't
really understand that sentence do do I
ever cover tolls old games yeah I
covered a lot of towels old games even
even tiles first recorded game it's not
really tells first recorded games it's
just that the Soviets you know refuse to
show games of their famous masters so
when they didn't play that great chess
do you want oh he wants to play here
yeah that's fine
strongest chess player of all time
Vaslav and Chuck that is known combi you
are noticed
mark we Daniels says are you brothers I
know man
do we look like I don't think so but we
are chess brothers yes we are just chess
chess King could I he'll have an alpha
zero on my channel as a guest co-host
that would definitely be great okay now
it's time for a you five-o captures you
capture Queen don't we capture one yeah
use the chocolate man yeah use the power
of the chocolate what time did you wake
up I hope I woke up at seven a prating
but one area says you look like Captain
America I guess that's a good thing
oh yeah I'll try this just oh I want to
bring my knight into the action wasn't
f5 a better at the idea that maybe
because yeah okay if he pushed that
fight now that's would have been yeah
this is looking nice I like this
hey you need another choco bar okay I
don't really
oh it's okay yes for for anyone who
still wishes to join the tournament
they're still like half an hour left 31
minutes and 40 seconds to be exact you
can still join the tournament by
clicking on the link in the description
below and half an hour's plenty of time
ie
I mean you can still even win the
tournament just maybe take one C 500 d5
No thank you thank you used a high
Barger congratulations mr. Hitler mr.
Hitler yes he won't he defeated an 1800
player and he's 1700 he feels very proud
that's that's always a good thing being
a higher rated player yes okay so did I
want a pawn or blunder or something hmm
well it's a good thing you have that
night there mmm Queenie for wood that'll
be a disaster yeah okay let's take this
and now if he takes here I'll exchange I
will pre move this and now comes Bishop
h4
mm-hm or simply rogue d8 would be a
plain night of - I'm looking good
tonight have - and then and then not
have to and then [ __ ] [ __ ] for okay
how to create some counterplay yes then
maybe I can just take on c7 Rudy 8 and
then [ __ ] [ __ ] for I think was better
he heard us I think he heard let's just
play well I get checkmated though hope
not opener but you might lose in time ok
I will just give up a rock because now I
can push him in a 4 and well that's a
reasonable plan no kings you're too
young king could be safe yes oh that's
very unfortunate now looking good here
let's play here is 6 is the move yeah I
don't care about this I don't think it
can even infiltrate I just capture the
night probably know it does he have any
moves here he has one second ok
let's play here and then my check okay
okay this was a long that was a great
victory
yeah well it's okay I mean you you can't
really comment on anything so okay the
first one has 28 points and I have are
you played against Ashish right no you
haven't
no it was a similar we have Leo poke
poachy or pokey or Posey and they you
get paired so fast I didn't really even
get a chance to read who's in the top
ten
maybe I should resort some games to to
get into the top yeah well this was a
this was a good opportunity although you
should play sharper moves yeah for
berserk games definitely jigs Justin of
course I see the comments I just have to
you know check out the game as well okay
he already dropped the piece that's now
a congratulations polycon and crushing
your father so it's always a special
moment can he take ah the rapids have
started okay we're just gonna finish the
tournament and do a couple of more
challenges and then I'm I'm probably
gonna enjoy the rapids as well Bishop g4
is also here double up the rooks yeah
also threatening to take on h2 or even
here
I was just take take
okay play this don't let the Kings
escape let's try this
King c4 up d8 or no okay then he loses
okay check me yeah that's a good one
that's a good one okay can't use the
link on the leech SFB I've never tried
actually joining from elite chess app
but I'm pretty sure you can just scroll
the tournaments find the tournament and
then just you know enter which is the
best opening against a stronger player
the one you feel most comfortable
comfortable with that is true oh it's
rotten blue cheese rotten blue cheese oh
yes he's been joining the streams from
the first time I've been streaming as
you can see we already played seven
games okay I took at the center so that
is good Wow we'll just please okay
oh he's blocking everything there's time
there's no rush
well yes you've reserved of course he's
blocking he doesn't want open lines now
maybe yes I thought that for but now
this is no night c100 order yeah yeah
he's really in there I'm just also
transfer mine I know Serbian players I I
don't know who the best Serbian player
is and g6 is looking good
why that's Croatian flag have a
chessboard I feel like I should know
this but it actually doesn't it's not I
mean it's not a chessboard
yeah it's sure hunt and we just call it
that
but it's not related to chess
yeah you can't you know just you know
drop a Croatian flag on the floor and
play chess
okay
well I've been busy covering the
covering the rapid championship so I did
take a break form from the Coulson app I
will get back to it though eventually
he's really making you work for it huh
yeah
25 seconds can you do this before he's
gonna check you can't remove that Oh
oh he really did a nice job locking this
position hmm okay he's just gonna repeat
use the c-51 don't care I want to
infiltrate okay and there is there it is
okay maybe just push the deep on yeah
well you are down to ten seconds okay
yeah the problem is that I don't hear
the sound you know yeah I know I know
maybe I'm not sure
yeah he has a minute more so oh here's a
minute more but if you if you grab all
of his pieces then it doesn't matter
first bin okay oh this is this is
intense
ah [ __ ] what am i doing
okay good berserk okay okay well I stood
up what
come on man I didn't think that was
gonna happen I seriously didn't think
that was gonna happen you messed it up
for such a clean draw Oh mr. rotten blue
cheese that is too bad
good game though plays berserk another
clean draw we should be fine let's take
here
it's mr. mr. plastic horse okay
I didn't plan you for you to take like
that maybe you know I will play fast so
your oh you Castle quits ha ha ha okay
not sure this is good for your bishop
what's trying to kill him
well okay
you know some games of Richard ready
yeah I definitely will even do a series
on Richard ready but there are so many
players yeah you know you can't cover
all of them I mean you you could but not
not all at once I guess but I am
planning to I still have to do a series
on Akiba ravine Stein and that epic
tournament of 1905 do ever play for four
players chips no I think that's a I
think that's a terrible idea
you know there's nothing wrong with to
play chess why why make a four player
chess if you have four people just you
know use two boards
matter is exactly right there I think
you could actually see him if I just
move a bit okay do I want to do this he
wants to open the center yeah some games
of capablanca as well yeah sure but I
will save those classic games for when
there's no actual tournament going on in
the world as there now is the rapid
championship and the blitz championship
will follow on the 29th and 30th so you
know there's always 2018 with Troy at 97
okay that is looking good because he
will probably move his rook a Quadros
osika and we are from new jersey take
here and take the audits and play even
even I can play this six after that
because he cannot move his night because
the rook here is falling down yes well
you are upper Queen yeah but always have
to win faster because of the time and
the berserk can i play a six first just
open it yeah we should be eight this 76
oh here take this
he cannot move his oh just a terrible
position for mr. plastic horse out I
played these seven probably even and
okay that's it I'll probably catch this
but play d7 playing Bishop g5 okay today
capture capture capture yeah he's gonna
grab the bishop that was nothing he
refuses Oh 10th place yes and feed a
master James Bond is still in second
place he had two games less to play then
Ashish to 2003 although he paused now so
it's gonna be gonna be a race to the end
you are playing against AI gambit my
king sounds like an apple product
sounds like very very ok don't like this
one actually no it's YouTube 21 Darko
YouTube 18 was like three tournaments
ago hey Lucas go in hello man a video on
Domino's defense I already did the one
video on the Munoz defense it's actually
I'm playing against it will there be
another tournament afterwards no we're
just gonna finish this one and probably
keep the stream open for another half an
hour maybe 40 minutes and they accept
some challenges
okay
probably play hey meadow isn't really
interested you know he he'd really does
what he wants to do yeah play g3 you
didn't berserk no okay okay no I have to
find some how he was with h4 I don't
really see any ideas for you absolute
three have to open up a bit I mean his
King is open as well so yeah although
that route from C one would really enjoy
coming to c7 I could imagine what state
but he will okay let's see what he does
oh I should have captured what not the
night with the not the night yeah now
push f3 and blunder the Queen yeah maybe
yeah I think that's that's exactly
what's gonna happen
porque will push g3 and I will just take
because I can what's a good move for him
something like Rock h8 I was just take
yeah it's not a good move maybe he'll
gambit gambit his what's the easier
thing I want to take me to maybe after I
didn't want to know rooks e7 first with
the temple
that's also good yeah yeah but that was
playing to do that later first I want to
relieve the stress here oh yeah look at
the powerful rock on e8 well that rope
could become very powerful okay now
because youngest I want to infiltrate
before whatever he plays okay not
whatever you please no no
okay just yeah at least defend that one
you can't really okay he did it so so he
can yeah okay but he seems like we have
a we have a classic night versus Bishop
endgame and it's gonna be very fun to
see how they play it out
we'll try yeah
what position is better even though
black has a bishop but oh we're equal in
those pawns are too scattered yeah okay
but he's playing good yes oh he's
defending that but it's for me to make
my position worse yes I don't want to
suggest anything I just it's it's not
not the best
next to Akkad matter is young almighty
he is my just shake him see what he does
oh I actually would have gone for a
three before or before immediately even
better stopping a five and then a three
oh okay oh [ __ ] again I will lose some
time there is always plenty of time
I haven't suggested anything yet
regarding what I'm sorry I must have
missed the comment Hitler says gin is
your name it's not Jenna actually see on
JN if he's really taking this time on
this one yeah even though you're really
not threatening anything oh you know
okay this is what I be three yeah yes
it's looking good now I can take like
this hmm I can just remove this check
him here
okay take here okay well you really grab
those two points very nice
okay oh do you have the fork do you have
the fork no you don't oh he's so fast
no not fast enough for Yann Almighty
okay we have ostrich 2003 in first place
little poachy in second and the feeder
master James Bond in third followed by a
bottled one emulate Coco Zener okay so
uh sure she is really killing the
tournament yes he is really killing the
tournament already up 91 yellow wall not
evil points but 91 points that's right
again for the declines hello sigh from
Bangladesh I made a video about ground
master from Bangladesh the other day he
didn't lose the game but you know
happens I think he's the only
Grandmaster from Bangladesh actually
okay can't remember the name I know it
has four letters something like Emre or
something a Morris man Morris fable good
fortress
okay I'm not looking good here not
looking good actually looking really bad
well I did I play b3 oh [ __ ] okay I mean
there's no threat here yeah it is
my c2 really you think Knights you do is
a threat
yeah why because I cannot move my rope
push f5 there is no time to think about
the rook let's I want to at least
recover a piece but can I do that
hmm yeah I will have to do it I don't
think you will capture it that rookies
useless okay
he will capture it there was no reason
to capture it that route couldn't move
yeah but it is a rook yes but you can
always capture it better was I don't
know that or bishop before even I just
develop you up go yeah
King sighs Wow let's see what happens
okay night I for probably not the best
in this situation but a hazelnuts from
Damascus Syria
Aeneas yes Nia's Mashhad Nia's Murshid
are you have five grand masters in
Bangladesh I thought yeah he was the
first he's not the only one yeah I I
knew it was four letters make a video
for a Greek Grandmaster I have made a
couple of videos from Greek grandmasters
which tournament is Zagreb is that which
tournament in Zagreb is this week the
one Kasparov is having in in a western
hotel
I think the blitz are the blitz no I
think you had to qualify for that
tournament yeah and the qualification
was I know that vehicle Drake Drake who
played a qualification I don't think he
qualified he didn't qualify
he was 7th but the first six qualify ok
are you left-handed yes sir why are we
playing with the right hand because I
I'm just kidding man as all things in
life everything is dedicated to
right-handed to people so I had to learn
how to play how to use that move I just
want to stop his Queen from going inside
the position and now I'm trying to I
think f5 immediately would yeah that was
a mom also my plan but Queen c2 is just
I think too powerful at this point I
hope play a fight now and I will try to
beat him down but we will see yeah okay
in 5g5 when he if you take g5 and he
loses the night yes but he will push her
for now and then he has that five for
the night okay
haha let's open up oh if you capture
that he's just gonna move the bishop and
that point is gonna be blocking oh no
he's not okay okay you are you are doing
well am I hope I am
what's great some threats I don't think
that's a threat
now Roxy one no oh
even this huh I think I have to change
the Queen's
it's gonna be a wild game but you are up
on time so maybe you should use that
let's bring the king oh I like it
working active King is the best okay oh
no I cannot
yeah both of your Knights are screwed
Bishop h6 but it's okay he didn't go for
it now Bishop h6 no no yeah
- Knights are very very hard to play
against when you're a long time now I'll
put the a pawn
no he doesn't want to push his own pawns
he's not the one second you should use
that
oh no that was a nice game okay fifth
place with five minutes to go I think it
could actually reach top three yeah but
I think I'm not sure if I can overcome
him in the end you can with you need one
win with berserk Oh berserk yeah okay
then we will Brazil there is always
berserk against chloride when I think I
have to preserve just a management yeah
thank the dirty flag well it's not dirty
I mean your opponent spent a lot of time
yeah it's only for he berserk as well
okay so fair game seems only fair yeah
yeah I heard that not Nakamura said in
one of his dreams
yeah it's just that the the guys using a
lot of time and that's his fault you
know yeah
all this Farrington love interest okay
I'm having an open yeah I think your huh
okay I think he handled that decently
although now it's okay ah no yeah Oh
should have played you [ __ ] but okay
what if I would have actually wind the
Queen yeah I should have played that g5
was a great move but you are better in
these kinds of positions so juicy porn
why not and what now f5 no okay can i
play f4 f5 yes beware of Greeks giving
gifts I think that was actually the
title of my video can i play this not
sure
what okay now he simplified a lot and
you are up upon but against two nights
could be dangerous if he uses those
nights oh I cannot take that okay okay
oh you could push I'm not gonna say it
don't say it
will there be a New Year's Eve stream
well even if there won't be any chest I
will I will definitely stream at least
you know some some drinks and food okay
I don't think he's gonna capture that
doesn't make sense he will try to flag
you although I don't think he can do it
with you still have 17 seconds and
that's one powerful pawn you're pushing
yeah yeah okay I baby it's time for one
more brother yeah I mean it doesn't if
you berserk that's 38 and if he wins
that's 40 so I don't think it matters if
you berserk or not I'll preserve because
I know that my opponents also play
faster if I have all time okay that's
what I okay modern mini I I started the
well I didn't start this year I started
last year but not not that intensively
how many GM's are in Croatia
I'd say about 12 but I'm not sure I'd
say about 12 or 14 maybe probably twelve
berserk
but berserk means you get half the time
on your clock and you get one extra
point if you win the game so it's a
pretty doubled edge edge decision
okay complete that if I go we know there
are some nasty tactics here maybe
Queenie if I was better or he could have
gone yeah so equal material opposite to
colored bishops are on the board
Oh her nice yeah Rocky eight followed by
Bishop g4 now you he's not gonna treat
Queens now oh yes well yeah but I won't
manage in time what are my thoughts on
animals Chuck not defending her titles
in Saudi Arabia well yeah start to say I
will I am planning a video on that so
probably maybe today or tomorrow but
it's a tough decision that there's a
really not a lot of money in chests well
you know they're trying to get some
money in chests by you know having a lot
of sponsors so is it is it a good choice
I don't know I'm sure I mean I'm sure it
is but will it make a difference I don't
think so
what what bothers me more is that she's
not playing so that's that's the real
thing that's that's the problem here
oh wow yeah yeah
didn't make it just played you okay or
this 454 g5 uh yeah there's plenty of
time unfortunately yes
wearable hip led you to know then here
oh yeah okay
can I take well no I want to go into
that now has to
now I can take
you know I can take the bishop but he
will move the bishop he won't g3 looking
good here yeah but unfortunately he
won't resigned he doesn't want to let
you have the points if he doesn't resign
you will not hold the point in g4 oh
very nice
and did you get the points now let me
see let me check I didn't get the points
yeah if you need even the rating points
yeah you get rating points but you don't
get the points for the tournament but
almost and our chief managed to lose the
game in the end so he almost played a
perfect tournament ninety-three percent
to win rate it's very nice yeah very
good
I've eaten that chocolate bar much
sooner yeah really sorry guys don't know
what got into me so now now I have more
time to pay attention to the to the chat
do you want to play a game yeah some
challenges okay now I will I'm gonna
look at your blunders yes if there will
be any haha they'd have any chocolate
bars left for you nope I'm chocolate
Alice okay I will open up a new tab
since I will publish the results of this
tournament on my Facebook and Twitter
page so be sure to congratulate everyone
it was a yeah I'm really glad that I
managed to play against Alda yeah yeah
it was a good game but he might he might
those who join us sometime in the future
okay let's let's see some challenges
make it a make it a three minutes
without increment or less and rotten
bleu cheese is already here what a
bullets challenge managed to get 9th
place okay let's let's see mr. rotten
blue cheese no I think I got much raise
right handed I'm actually left-handed
okay I just only write with my right
hand
oh yeah yeah
rotten blue cheese yeah I played against
him and him as the messed up and yes the
perfect draw the promotion and he's a
very quick player Oh what is this what
is this let's go here and but he is
playing against a hyper bullet guy so no
I'm glad he can i'm the ultra bullet
master how ultra ball okay
although he i'm not really playing that
fast here since i don't hear the moves
okay Bishop g4 seems like a good place
to develop the bishop so yeah you can
challenge if you go to Lee chest and
enter you have this swords which are
essentially like a challenge but you
entered the nick agamotto
and what is he doing you can then have a
challenge and please please challenge to
a three minute or less yeah sure rookie
[ __ ] off he's gonna double up okay I
don't mind
I'll let's capture here okay I think
you're looking good of course okay and I
need a very long time I'll just capture
here and capture here oh here here what
sorcery is this
oh here okay good game mister blue
rotten cheese we live in Krieger team
which is a small town 60 kilometers
north from Zagreb the categorisation oh
also an opponent from the tournament you
played him in the tournament yes yeah
one of the last games oh we have the
Sicilian we might go for some okay it
this is the worst possible position
where you can play before so let's see
how he fares against it you know
something some people do some people
actually a three and now if you take
something yeah and now I play Bishop
here so it's a very complicated position
I just think you're lost upon it's a
complicated position but in every
development yes I do and that's what I'm
going for here let's go
d4
after he captures she's not gonna
capture was just capture capture and it
goes that I mean 83 we're very positive
is really we have and we actually have a
lot of people from Malika okay okay and
I'm threatening to win back okay he
wants to go 95 I don't want that to
happen
let's just get the rook into the game
with tempo and maybe maybe get some
action here yeah capture capture Oriakhi
is like a chess
one of the major chess capitals and I
delicious is the biggest yeah there are
a lot of clubs okay let's make let's go
let's go here I actually played for a
Ryoka chess club in my younger days
Oh even more people from Rijeka wow
thanks mr. chloride okay somebody has
cousins is in Eureka as well nice I
thought I had Bishop captures f7 but I
don't that's unfortunate
oh well I always have if I go a3 he he
can exchange the light square bishop
that's unfortunate
oh man it's actually it's actually
really bad okay hello to people from
Germany as well Queen before okay
which is the chess capital of the world
III think Reykjavik maybe Joe Gaza Bobby
Fischer
Auriga because it's al yes I mean one of
those definitely okay and I'm getting
lower on time he's still I don't want to
give up this Bishop just to capture this
pawn but I don't really think but you
cannot do it because he will recapture
and - I came to do it now but I will be
able to do it at some point
that is true huh okay let's bring the
other rook here about who is the chess
capital so I think or Baku yeah
Irina is for Marco's Oh a lot of players
are from Baku about cool a big city hmm
uh-oh
I don't really have a choice here
although there are some nasty tactics
here now yeah they're just Amanda green
yeah or not it's unfortunate now I just
push the win this is drawing on the
board is very cool yeah we discovered
that one of these dreams yeah it was a
it was a good game alright but I managed
to trick you that's unfortunate my still
a fan of young Misha well of course I
mean I haven't seen any of his games
until those I've shown Michael keen also
a frequent follower of of the streams
and what is more important endgame
opening or middle game oh I'm always for
endgame but you know that's difficult to
say there they're all important because
yeah they all collectively
[Music]
besides the result you know yeah
definitely
ah that he doesn't want to capture my
porn
I think this too I just like that I
think my teacher taught me never to play
Bishop d3 in this position because you
can play immediately d5 inning for ya
okay but maybe it's some sort of a hyper
modern idea maybe place III and Bishop
c2 and then d4 oh okay it's a late it's
a late this will this will give me
plenty of chances to sacrifice for
example if he captures my pawn I can
capture on f2 seems like a reasonable
choice he was g3 queen here and then I
picked up the knight or drug it seems
possible but we'll see oh he ignored it
yeah he wants to check me too I mean why
wouldn't he ignore it or if I go Queenie
7th you're just gonna put d4 and then I
grab the rope
so seems reasonable Michael King is a
snake i I think that when you start
learning it's best to start with the end
endgame
because you have to know how to end the
game and how to check make your alright
if one but that's my thinking that's I
mean resting I mean if you learn how to
play openings it's just you open the
position and then what you don't really
have the idea ah I think with the end
game you really get to know chess yeah
if you couldn't capture Bishop c5 would
win the game immediately
that's some sneaky moves you got there
top three favorite anime do you watch
anime at all you know I watch enemy know
who gave you all the Dragonball episode
ok Dragonball
okay Dragon Ball but besides Dragon Ball
yeah I've watched Naruto but maybe only
that's a long one
yeah but I watched like 30 episodes
maybe altogether I kind of enjoyed that
one but I mean Dragonball is definitely
one of the one of the ones which bring
good memories but did you watch that no
maybe yes I have oh that I like that one
Oh occupied area taking my bishop see
I'm talking to you and I totally yeah
that's what happens to me and then you
blame it on something but I still have a
superior endgame so I don't mind I think
that no code geass yeah yeah I know
awesome awesome anime yeah I've heard of
that one but it's really like well
thought the plot and everything this
code yes it has to I think there are two
animes but but yeah that that was like
really really really good writing on
that one hmm in everything else did you
did you watch already called that one
with the where there's that alchemy
involves Full Metal Alchemist full metal
optimist yeah no I haven't but I've seen
I've seen our cards okay it's like
Dracula backwards okay
if he really is a Dracula okay this is
quite a quite a superior endgame so yeah
don't really a lot of pest I think I can
win this just by stepping on the light
squares like okay pretty much you know
right now who is this guy by Ivan Madar
a one-punch man yeah one punch man is
awesome sight ah oh yeah
Donna is a beast they really like it on
IMDB yeah yeah but I didn't yet watch it
I am a young almighty for all of you who
don't know ask all the time
it's director is there a chess enemy
well if there isn't there should be one
I think that they play chess in code yes
yeah yeah it's like strategy and
everything you know there's a shogi
enemy yeah well of course there was a
shogi enemy okay
all right not really
he blocks with the bishop I'll just pick
up this pawn okay hmm can't can't have
everything I guess
do you know any Austrian chess players
Austrian chess players pretty sure I do
but I just don't remember their Austrian
at the moment isn't that one mark was
rug rug something now I think there is
one but I'm not sure it's Austria good
he might be trying to flag me here but
he has less time than you yes I know low
soapy okay let me just check from the
bottom Miquel tool he's counting on me
talking to you yes and then you just
blend her away okay let's just accept a
couple more and you can then place if
you want one more or two and I have to
get back to the dredge Rapids okay
well then I will just go home and wait
for you to upload the videos or you can
you can help me make some oh okay
I don't know if you guys would like that
mommy the verses for the save biggest
joke of the tournament I will definitely
check it out
Tiny's is Austrian yes okay so we get
everyone yeah but I thought yeah current
Valeris okay
three guards so no lion I'm gonna put
each five here yeah play some tell moose
there's no reason to ok and now G from
now the e for five
you should always appreciate the open G
file yes
yeah well okay so okay mate I'll talk
about it with Ivan matter and uh what
about if you want to make a video you
want me to help you make a video oh yeah
sure you can make the entire thing I
could use okay oh you could use a break
yeah what should I say at the beginning
hello everyone or of course hello
everybody
ah I should I should change it maybe no
you're making it you choose okay okay
I'll think about it
oh you're playing it planning something
nasty on the h2 square uh in couple of
moves yes but I did leave this pawn here
hanging oh he decided to defend it so
not g5 come yeah of course
ah now we ignore this do we ignore it
but afterwards it's with tempo so yeah I
know
okay let's capture it
there is no defense all the white pieces
are undeveloped this is not good
you should use hello fellas hello fellas
or maybe maybe like a pirate yeah okay
suggest something guys I don't think he
oh why okay he thought your night is too
powerful
I mean it was it's a good call
but now this is just weird yes that's
maybe I convinced him that there is no
defense because I said so I was only
kidding okay okay it was a good game
okay one more challenge okay NP dude
okay and P do it is also a frequent
follower although I call him mr. nude
okay if it'll save your body above a
match did they play against each other
I'm sure they have both of them were
always yeah I talk but I'm really
looking forward to covering sweedler vs
Abama yeah Alex fiddler it's really a
mighty game say hello Ibrahim and others
okay uh I guess d4 now I've never tried
shogi actually yeah well what is surely
the Japanese version of well not of
chess but of their kind of a cool game
I've heard of go with the stones yeah I
never heard of show me shogi is also a
thing okay yeah I do sometimes play at
all but you know poorly
okay you're getting a lot of messages
man yeah people people are asking me
what am I doing here I should be at home
or something
oh it's why why am I not drinking
business my move and it's time to push
me five definitely we must strike while
the iron's hot that's how they say he
will capture and I will now play Bishop
c4
okay what about East six completely six
I don't mind I don't mind protect your
king
now he's oh he was gonna go there okay
rocky one
okay you'll teach me for if I teach you
chess okay sounds reasonable
yeah that's unreasonable okay he's uh I
don't know like there are you a good
sugar player do you have a some kind of
a rating system and show you like you
haven't chess or something
are there others there is like it's like
it's is it played only in Japan or I
don't think so
let's go Queen III okay III gave up a
lot of pawns I should probably make some
progress here he's preparing to castle
it's very unfortunate yeah although you
should just play h3 yes
h3 is actually the best and then second
floor yes it's exactly what I was going
to say yeah I know your style can you
get better just from learning on the
Internet
mmm I don't know but playing on the
internet or watching educational videos
or what do you mean I mean just by
playing blitz games I don't think so but
if you would play like longer games
without using the engine or some help
maybe no yeah I mean fence if you play
and then analyze your games I guess you
could you could probably get somewhere
but I below I will always suggest to
people who start learning chess to start
from the end game and then learn some
openings the strategy terrible just try
some openings that will suit you the
best and then my thinking is read some
of those strategy tactic books to get a
feeling for the middle game indeed and
yeah that should pretty much admit
oki castle interesting it's covering
pretty good on e7 so but now it's time
to really go for it your bishop wouldn't
be too isn't well it's a mighty piece
maybe you can take on d4 mm-hmm can you
probably but I refuse to activate the
bishop he cannot take because on e7 you
are but I'm not sure can even play King
this it leave you to your thinking but
you have half a minute so beware oh
thanks
thank you sir which book do you advise
for openings I don't know a book for
opening stats oh that was actually
hanging yeah my bed I mean I think on
every side you know have those opening
books where you can just go through
moose yeah there isn't like any I mean
yeah you could probably use a book where
you can just see what are the
explanations for is somebody's playing
some moves but I'm not really aware of
any good ones yeah where did my time go
oh oh that's just terrible okay
that's just terrible mr. MP dude 2004
yeah he really destroyed me
good job sir
yeah you're dropping a queen oh you
didn't take it I have to I have to win
on time there is no other way to do it
really yes oh there that's some nice
tactic Oh
again good game mr. nothing good give up
the bishop as well he totally he totally
refuted might be four idea very nice
okay we have time for one more so I want
to go yeah okay let's
let's end it with some crazy yes I'm in
the end and then we have to we have to
return to the world rapid championship
ok is this good h3 yeah I think he was
next yes
okay let's okay
some gambit variation yeah I'd have to
do a stream once without making the
tournament so more people will be able
to the challenge but I don't know I
guess people really enjoy tournament
yeah exactly it's also my thing okay
he isn't online yeah not too bad should
I okay let's challenge I think we have
to abort first but okay maybe it will
automatically abort
maybe we should age rider the livestream
will end after Jung plays one more game
since we said it will be a two hour
stream tournament plus a couple of Road
a couple of games we didn't really know
if if anyone will show up since the
stream was unannounced but it was
actually was actually one of the more
popular streams over 700 people I
believe at one point what do people like
more just playing challenges or playing
tournaments
I think tournaments and challenges in
that order yes you can never have enough
chest
for endgame
I don't know if you don't have any any
options of acquiring a book or something
I actually really enjoyed the george
watsons academy on chess master 11 the
grandmaster edition that's really nice
endgame techniques there you know you
have everything like Bishop against
Knight night against Bishop opposite
color bishops a lot of good things and
there is not only end games there's also
a psychology and chess part attacking in
chess pretty much everything so you know
if you're below 1800 I think that's
that's gonna do a lot of good
hey I Roux no I didn't have a channel
before I got matter I did have one
although it was this one I just hid all
the videos that were on this one and I
just started uploading chest videos the
other videos are still on my channel
they are just invisible
I try this
jingis one no you don't want to push
that five yeah my saying and they will
just take but now take you I was
planning on doing this first you know
okay and then if you play screen here
just look here we'll see but I'm
completing night see for the other night
from D to know but now Knight captures
f5 is dangerous
yeah it was dangerous before as well I
let's just take this rook
well okay she can't castle soul yeah now
we have oh about that's fine now we'll
just check him here and this check me
yep if he doesn't do anything about it
probably 94 is coming although he can
probably hear it no nobody wants to play
here can I just get into a windmill no I
wish okay she didn't see that okay yeah
good game yeah okay well that's it for a
stream you want to say anything for for
the end of the stream yeah guys thanks
for having me it was a nice tournament I
saw free I started with all those
blundering games yeah but that chocolate
bar really happened yeah okay but you
don't have to win all the games you know
it's yeah I wanna show my best game but
yeah fortunately it's not always the
case on stream but yeah yeah thanks and
yeah that's everything for this stream
like I said as usual I will post the the
news about the winners of the tournament
here they are I will do it on my
Facebook and Twitter page make sure to
congratulate everyone
archers 2003 Leo pochi and James Bond in
third place and everyone else who
followed will try to make some more
streams who knows maybe even tomorrow
see how it goes and I have to go cover
the world rapid chess championship now
so that's it thank you all and I will
see you soon